do you have a philosophy of mathematics
and if so what is it
philosophy of mathematics well this is
this is like the question about
what the right foundation should be and
as i said my that there are several
underlying philosophies
so there's finitism where you think
everything should be computation and
platonism where you think everything
exists in some mystical realm and
there's
formalism where it's just a game you
play
with with with rules and
i'd say i i sort of
kind of oscillate between them or maybe
amalgamate them all
i mean that they they all have some good
points and some bad
points so i don't really have a single
philosophy i just sort of
um kind of amalgamate all philosophies
and pick and choose whichever is most
convenient at the time
and it seems you know there seems to be
something a little bit off about this
it's like trying to belong to several
different religions all at once
but but somehow for mathematical
philosophies maybe you can get away with
it
what do you mean you pick and choose
which one's useful what would be an
example of one that's useful for you
um well i i mean i think the different
philosophy
wouldn't really be useful for actually
doing math research that the different
philosophies would be
useful for trying to understand what the
foundations of mathematics and the
universe
are so if you if you think the universe
should be based on computation then
maybe you try working with a
finitistic computational model of
mathematics
um if you if you're trying to understand
some
deep complicated theorem then
it's it's very difficult to prove these
theorems in a finite artistic model so
you may have to sort of switch to a
more platonic model where there is you
know you
you you assume the existence of very
strong constructions like the power set
of a set
i mean it's it's very difficult
developing things like general topology
for example in a
in a finite artistic universe